Yeah, you're right to look
worried mate. That's a dingo. Oh
god. Australia has its very own
wild doggo and it's called the
dingo. Oh, but how deadly is it?
I'm Ann Jones from ABC Science,
and it's my job to watch viral
videos of dingoes.
The bastard's got my camera.
Stand still mate. Stand still.
While you're here, if you like
this sort of video, why don't
you hit subscribe? And that way
you won't miss it when we upload
the next one. Let's crack on.
Oh my god. I want to scratch the
belly. Little white tootsies.
But dingoes are not domestic
dogs. They're a wild animal.
They're closer to the grey wolf
of east Asia than they are to
our blue heeler, right? They
will have that more like sort of
greyhound-esque sort of body
that goes really slim in the
abdomen, and pretty agile and
muscular looking legs ready to
run around. And on top of that,
really mobile joints and that
includes their necks because
unlike domestic dogs, a dingo
can look over his shoulder. How
you doing?
Oh, hello.
He, she, it's just used it's
little snoot. I read about him
in a research paper that came
out of Melbourne. There's a
dingo research institute there
is such a complex set of
movements it's not only lifting
the latch it's using its body
weight to push the door. But
it's the ears that are the
problem mate. See that ear go
bonk.
Ahhhh!! How cool is that? That
is problem-solving at its
absolute very best. Tool use,
especially spontaneous tool use,
as in tool used that isn't
encouraged by humans, is a sight
to behold and extremely rare and
hasn't been seen in other
canines. Next one. Hey, I'm here
on K'gari. And it's really
exciting because there are two
dingoes and one is coming
towards us. (laughs) This is one
of my videos from Fraser Island.
And luckily I got Conway with
me. He is going to tell us all
about 'em. Look, look.
Ann, they're wongaris in our
language.
Wongari! Yeah. Conway Burns, who
is one of the indigenous rangers
who works on the island, he gave
me a lesson or two in wongari
culture.
Once upon a time there used to
be two types of dingoes here.
Focus Ann. Focus.
There was your domestic dingo,
the camp dingo.
Yeah.
Since all of our old people are
gone they're all wild. They're
all wongari.
They're all wongari. On K'gari
there's apparently like one to
200 dingoes and there's about 19
formed packs, and within that
they'll have a hierarchy that is
policed constantly. Those below
will constantly be trying to
rise and those above will
constantly be trying to stay on
top and be the leader of the
gang. Like when you see them
together, it's like watching a
soap opera. Yeah, only one can
be top dog. Are we still
rolling? Next video.
Just stand still mate. Just
stand still.
Good advice. That would be
intimidating.
Don't just don't. All that stuff
excites them.
No, that's okay.
What happens is sometimes when
they're really excited, they'll
come in and nip and bite.
Play for them involves biting.
Play for them involves
roughhousing and things like
that. And of course, in amongst
themselves, they can deal with
that. But if we get involved in
it, it's going to be a nasty
bite or a nip to one of your
limbs. The difference between
play and prey is nothing. Next
one.
I have lost my fiance the poor
baby.
Maybe the dingo ate your baby.
The dingo ate your baby.
It was gonna come up at some
point, right, this cultural
reference. And I think that that
isn't actually making fun of
dingos, it's making fun of
Australians. Yeah, look, dingoes
can be aggressive but they're
nowhere near as deadly as bad
acting.
Hi, little dingo! Oh wait a
second that's a whale! They will
eat anything. Dead crabs, dead
fish, they'll rip apart
coconuts. They'll even ate human
poos. So if you do have to go to
the toilet when you're on Fraser
Island, you need to bury it
really deep or else.
(howling)
That vocal slip, the weeeerrr. I
apologise to any cats watching.
Okay, campsite campsite. Oh, hi,
I was just, I just wanted a cup
of tea and I'll take this as I
go.
It's easy to be really scared of
something and demonise something
that actually isn't quite as bad
as we might make out. Consider
this every single year in
Australia in public hospitals,
there are something like 12 to
14,000 admissions due to
domestic dog bites. So 98 dingo
mullings over the course of 10
years versuses that, you can see
what's more deadly.
Yeah, let's get another one in.
Did it get someone's phone? Ah!
Look at those teeth. Longer than
dog teeth apparently, longer jaw
as well. Woah, who's that?
(laughs) Are they chasing it? I
love that the dingo pressed record.